oh cool cryptex can i have it no no you
can't where'd you get it how do you know
what a cryptex is i know what things are
well leslie hid the location of our
valentine's meeting place in here no
tried every five letter word that has
anything to do with our third date
have you tried
it's a four-letter word
an s i really don't think it's that uh i
wish i could help you bro i don't know
if i can you're like the second smartest
guy i know
you should go to the first smartest guy
i know
okay so the clue is inside but it takes
the five-letter code to open andy
did you try
ah yes why is that everyone's first
suggestion just smart people i think i
might be able to help you told you
[Music]
let me see it yeah you can i'll show you
i can unroll it the murals with this
heart you see look to the first and
there
your next clue will be the first letter
of the name of each mural with a heart
on it will spell out the clue
or some or something let's check out the
murals hello everyone and welcome to the
pawnee bicentennial scavenger hunt get
ready for a full day of hunting maybe
even days plural enough talking
clues please and thank you leslie warned
me that ron was a master puzzle solver
so i have outdone myself this is the
lady gaga of scavenger hunts a complete
work of genius wrapped up in a
disorienting mix of confusing cultural
red herrings
the treasure is buried beneath the
southwesternmost bench and ramsett park
how could you have possibly figured that
out already once i determined the
cryptex was a false lead i realized the
hidden clues on the scrolls could be
solved with incomplete columnar
transposition the transposed words
alphanumerically linked to numbers the
sequence of which suggested latitude and
longitude then it was simply a matter of
accessing my mental sextant i'm shocked
i ran this hunt planned by the indiana
puzzlers guild and they gave it five out
of five sherlock pipes
keep it and don't feel bad it's my curse
okay so we've got all the ones from this
side with the heart sticker
all right the ones from the other
hallway are cornfield slaughter lament
of the buffalo needless slaughter
slaughter gone wrong eating the reverend
it's raining blood and death everywhere
great i got it from here thanks guys i
hope i didn't screw up your valentine's
day too much oh god no april hates
valentine's day and brunch and outside
and smiling
she's weird i figured it out the letters
unscrambled say no food finer
clue three at jj's diner how many clues
are there exactly
i had it in a safe place and then i
moved it to protect it and i don't
remember where i see don't be mad ron
she hid it too good
then she left a string of clues
it's an impossible puzzle and i love
puzzles a minimal unhelpful note these
appear to be human teeth and what is
this twilight new moon it's a movie but
i've never seen it it's like about lame
werewolves and vampires and stuff donna
likes those things dollars to donuts
this points us her way finally a
scavenger hunt worthy of my time onward
okay there is no food finer for leslie
that means whipped cream or
no it's whipped cream everyone look in
the whipped cream cans
oh got some
nothing yet
okay something wicked this way comes
once you peruse a book with your thumbs
go to the one who succumbs i'll be
attached with a little gum oh come on
leslie give me a break i hate riddles
and other such nonsense i want that on
the record
but
something wicked with a book is my
ex-wife from the library which means i'm
the one that succumbs uh i'll be
attached with a little gum
good god that woman is good follow me to
the sheltered snow only 22 clues left to
go 22.
well
this is the woman i've chosen to love
well i guess there's nothing to do but
spend the entire night methodically
solving this puzzle we have a
wonderfully small number of clues one is
this ticket did you see this movie about
vampires and such new moon yeah i saw it
with april she was so hopped up on
painkillers from getting her wisdom
teeth out i convinced you to see it with
me the teeth they're yours you were
super out of it you kept feeling team
voldemort at the screen and we were
kicked out i was furious
you only get to see the second twilight
film for the seventh time once do you
remember anything about a key or april
doing anything unusual that day she did
make us stop by the shoe shine stand
before we left because she wanted to
drop something off for andy she had a
real bad crush on him oh
babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing we're married still to the
shoeshine stand
hello
my name is ron swanson i believe leslie
knope may have left some kind of
scavenger hunt clue here she did
one second
[Music]
gentlemen
[Music]
enjoy your evening
the shoeshine stand is gone
or maybe it was never here they must
have moved it during the remodel it's
probably in basement storage to the
basement
so i got nine three and four i have 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 and 19. whoa
i got i got lucky and i love riddles
tighter you sure do yeah do you tighter
i can do it do what exactly nothing
we're not doing anything and we
definitely do not live down here now
guys where's the old shoeshine stand
from upstairs we don't know anything
about that boys think we are on a quest
and we are not leaving until we get an
answer well we're on our own quest which
is to squeeze this just tight enough to
make my eyes bulge out a little bit but
not so tight that i die i've been there
that's a real tightrope walk oh hey
last week this real scary ghost came
down here looking for it it had black
hair but you could see through his skin
and it wouldn't talk to me it would only
talk to harris
no dude that was just that bonk's dream
that i had how we gonna have the same
dream dude cause we're best friends i
love you dawg i'll bet i love you
we dream it together
we sleep it together but not like that
can you tell us anything else about this
ghost
i mean just that it didn't like me but
that's just cause i got a soul of a
ghostbuster yeah it said something about
how i was worried brett was gonna mug it
okay so we're looking for a racist ghost
with black hair who likes shoeshines i
think i have the answer the chase
continues
we failed
i just had a little more time she's
waiting for me somewhere in pawnee and
i'm not gonna be there
wait leslie loves romance but she also
loves being right is there something you
used to disagree on but you've since
come around to her way of thinking
ron you're a genius
if you don't mind councilman milton we
just need to search this stand
yes
found it
hi andy i hate people but you are okay
it's weird woof woof april oh my god
baby you're so into me that's hilarious
that's it it's a dead end no more clues
see me in my office
leslie thanks to your annoying prying
last year i'm sure you remember my
birthday's coming up i know i know no
parties you hate parties correct
oh
you know that wild goose chase you sent
ben on for valentine's day the scavenger
hunt
i also do not want that yep i understand
i absolutely do not want to solve a
series of riddles and clues each more
intricate than the last
you understand what i'm saying yeah i
got it ron
good
oh i i do want that please do that for
me
what matters is that i trust you
and admire you as a person
i will be sorry to see you leave this
town for many reasons
not the least of which is that you
created a puzzle that even i couldn't
solve
and boy oh boy
did you love
andy woof woof
it really is embarrassing oh my god i
totally know where the key is
how'd you remember
wolf wolf
barf
why here
because this tree reminds me of you it's
strong and quiet
and always here when you need it
or whatever
i have always felt a certain kinship
with april and this is proof that i was
correct
not the nice things she said about me
the fact that i buried a large amount of
gold under that same tree years ago
i have since moved it
or have i
or was i lying the whole time
or was i lying about lying
or was there never any gold to begin
with
or
you